Oh mother thank you so much cuz you know
it's weird but I am same more nervous
about that and I was about the Olympics
this is just
weird cuz it's like you know the hundred
yards - is quite something
but lat whoa as they can see it your
skirt down there anyway Trailblazer
award
here we go glasses on I stop it come on
I'm old here he is a speech I picked up
the right one yes sir yes I can yeah
thank you miss Hinkle boom
she's a comedy genius who has
revolutionised sketch comedy on
television
barely a week going by in the last few
months about one of her hilarious on
point comedy sketches going for is this
about me I'd be furious I'd be furious
cuz there's the line young people out
there doing some great work really
seriously she's oh now I know it is
that's the name of the top right oh do
shut up come on
she's skewers this has been written for
me by the way I don't way I don't want
you to think I say over the words
skewers Kathy let's bear this in mind
she she skewers the contemporary
experience of being a woman better than
anyone else I agree as sketches like
girl you don't need make-up and last
[ __ ] day which was genius proof this
summer sees the release of trainwreck
the film she is both written and starred
in and frankly it's worth the ticket
price of the tampon gag alone I have to
say I got to know her because my
daughter here is also comedian and once
texted me and said you have to watch
this you have to watch this woman it's
the funniest [ __ ] stuff you will ever
ever see and I agree
she's one of Time Magazine's Most
Influential read isn't it
she's what
she's one of Time Magazine's Most
Influential People and tonight she's
just brilliant she's Glamour magazine's
trailblazer it's Amy Schumer